this is so sweet guys Will Smith getting
a little teary-eyed talking about his
oldest son Trey and how far their
relationship has come take a look at
this Instagram post yeah so I'm in Abu
Dhabi at the f1 I brought my son Trey
we've been hanging in and I usually I
take my kids separately on stuff just so
they have their individual daddy time so
we've been doing this and being him we
hanging at the f1 and he just hit me
with uh he said you know what Dad he's I
just realized you're not just my dad and
he paused and he said I'm pretty sure
you're my best friend and I was like
yeah man I love that so much will opened
up even more in the caption of one of
the photos he posted of him and Trey he
said quote we struggled for years after
my divorce from his mother he felt
betrayed and abandoned it is a wild
blessing to recover and restore a loving
relationship with my beautiful son so of
course Trey's mom is not Jada it's sure
a we know that will and sureiy remain
close will posted this fishery excuse me
he posted this throwback photo recently
wishing her happy birthday and even
calling her the best baby mama ever an
et just talked to Trey last month he
spoke to our own Denny director of et
live about how real his family gets cuz
they share quite a lot including those
emotional moments here's what Trey had
to say no we talked about you know it
gets real real like we talk about you
know all types of stuff you know what's
going on in everybody's lives and
whatnot and just you know trying to give
advice trying to just be there to
support and and really to you know not
only better ourselves but to help better
the tribe I don't know if there is a
more real family in Hollywood than the
Smiths of course we've covered so much
Jada's show red tabletalk and Sheree
actually went on read.table talked and
talked about wills commitment they
talked about you know things with him
and Jay
and Cherie and working things out with
their blended family so it's just
awesome to see cuz the actor being
honest about going through some
struggles as he split from Trey's mom
but keeping close and coming together to
co-parent and now they're best friends I
love it so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]